[Music]
people always think that it's just
sexual everything that it's happening
there but actually you havin a lot of
fun
people are always assuming that things
that happened over there are mostly
erotic intimate moments I mean a lot of
the guys they just want to talk it's
more about fun being wild on camera and
just being yourself those are actually
the most memorable stories so I have
many memorable stories I already knew
this guy I knew he was coming there for
only the fun and entertaining reasons he
didn't want anything sexy nothin to do
with it
he was watching you for a wild and
future to watch me my body moves and
things like that he's asked me like
could you please teach me how to be like
a sensual woman and how to attract man
of course we are not laughing about
anyone because it's part of the fetish
the memoral think it's his wheeling like
how much he was trying so at some point
he was ironing his clothes and taking me
private he started playing with me a
truth or dare I kind of lost it there
and I had to put a pile of clothes on me
I told him like just the way you are
looking keep your hand like this do like
this with your hair play with her hair
of course he didn't have hair so it was
funny like she was bald I was actually
teaching from how to work his hips just
something like shot here I said rather
was very funny he actually like at some
point she started to laugh so it was
memorable because he was so willing to
learn all these tips that I was giving
t-shirts sweatshirts three pairs of yoga
pants
afterwards me still being with the pile
of clothes on me I had to do some yoga
moves there was a member that literally
just wanting me to act like I was
speeding in his car I have
this member Kittleman private without
thanking me what's he wanna do he
literally just wanted me to like
roleplay out that I was speeding his car
and that I was cussing him out because
he was telling me to stop speeding and
it was just really different for me so
that's why I was so memorable me he just
told me act like you're speeding push
your foot down to the floor let me see
push the parts of the metal like and
tell me to shut up if he's popped it to
give me a video with Tom and Jerry and
to dress like Tom in blue jeans and the
white socks
yeah me like telling him to shut up that
I'm gonna go as fast as I want to go and
he just enjoy me yelling at him and
telling him that he was a punk for not
letting me speak to watch that video and
to act exactly like Tom how Tom octave
him absolutely those who like the back
you like him he didn't gave me his
camera probably he laughs and was also
funny I loved it somewhat I have fun we
have like a lot of memories stories but
overall all the experience it's actually
like helping you be more open-minded
after all like a person that is coming
on a site as a member he is trying to
get something new that it's not
happening actually in real and probably
he would never try Andrea so they want
something either if it's sexual or fun
they just want something new because if
everything would be just the same every
time would be kind of like boring so
having this kind of thing
giving the fact that it's also making
you laugh and it's like raising your
voice it's also helping you be more
open-minded
[Music]